all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with inferno yes we
are god this story is so good like the
ending of this is nuts okay so here's
the thing right so inferno as you guys
know in the the last video that we did
it was basically the return of destiny
which was one of the most terrifying
things for like xavier and magneto and
those guys because destiny is a precog
right where magneto and xavier are able
to guide krakowa under the auspices that
they know what's best for everybody and
that they have to just kind of trust
their leadership destiny can actually
see the future she actually knows what's
going to happen and that's kind of a
crazy thing here because when you're
dealing with someone who knows the
future suddenly the manipulations of
xavier and magneto become a lot harder
to implement but what this does is it
actually opens up with really some time
before all of this took place that you
actually have mystique who basically
begins the process of bringing destiny
back and that was the question that we
had right how did destiny somehow manage
to return how did that end up happening
and so what this does is it actually has
mystique basically traveling to island m
right the home of magneto essentially
right using the quinjet she arrives on
the scene then basically takes a helmet
of xavier makes herself look like
charles xavier and then goes to visit
sinister now the funny thing about this
is sinister immediately picks up on
what's going on right he's just like
look at you all dressed up always
playing a part as always right like
sinister immediately knows this is
mystique now a lot of this goes into
just the nature of sinister himself
right sinister's been around mystique
enough times to know what's going on
he's been around here enough times to
know when she's being manipulative and
xavier wouldn't really just show up and
visit sinister like this for this
particular thing the other part of this
is that because sinister hands mistakes
something it looks like it was a
pre-arranged meeting right so sinister
already kind of knew that it was
mystique when she showed up here but the
important thing is that this leads to
mystique pretending to be xavier showing
up to the five now as you guys know the
five are the ones who are responsible
for resurrecting dead mutants and then
restoring their memories to them all
that kind of cool stuff right the whole
resurrection process now the other thing
about this is that by and large when it
comes to those individuals those members
of the five their belief in xavier is
beyond contestation they don't question
him they take what xavier does as an
absolute truth and so when he shows up
and he hands them a vial which is going
to serve the purpose of resurrecting a
dead mutant and he says this is to bring
this mutant back at the end of the day
they're like okay they don't question
it's not like how did you get this like
what's going on here like this is an
unexpected resurrection none of that
happens instead it's just like okay cool
so of course they inject the vial into
the resurrection pod and then from there
destiny basically re-emerges now the
cool thing about this and one of the
things to keep in mind when it comes to
resurrection is you're basically a clean
slate this was jonathan hickman
borrowing heavily from the eternals
right the eternals have been doing this
for for eons right for about a million
years or so since their existence every
time any turtle dies they basically come
back in this exact same capacity i mean
it doesn't follow the exact form right
they're not born in an egg instead it's
basically just a body for themselves
that's created by the machine right the
the earth itself right but the systems
that were left behind by the celestials
and so when the question's asked by uh
by hope summers okay xavier are you
ready to give her her memories of course
whenever mystique turns into someone she
cannot copy their powers she's not
capable of that so when the question's
asked are you ready mystique has to find
a way to dodge the question which she
does in a fantastic fashion she actually
plays on the nature of hope summers
right so for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with this after the scholar
which had taken away 98 of the mutant
population's powers hope summers was the
first mutant who was born after what was
referred to as m day and in fact she is
hugely powerful but the reason why she's
called hope summers is because she was
adopted by cable who's the child of
cyclops and madeleine pryor the fact
that hope looks like jean grey in a lot
of ways that was marvel initially
teasing the idea that jean grey was
gonna come back and then basically
pulling the rug out from everybody and
saying actually it's a girl named hope
you know and that was basically it right
it's not jean grey it's just a girl
named hope and she looks like jean grey
jean grey will maybe come back at a
future point in time but the thing about
this is that mystique plays on that it
says like you're the one of the most
powerful mutants in existence that's why
we put you here as part of the
resurrection process like literally hope
summers has the ability to duplicate the
powers of anybody she's around and
amplify the powers of people she's
around right there's seemingly no upper
limit to those powers we haven't seen
how far it can go but i imagine it can
go pretty daggone far but hope summers
is kind of like i mean i've never done
this before so yeah sure i'm definitely
excited about this right and so at that
point miss sleek's like cool right
here's the helmet do your thing and so
as hope goes through and basically finds
what is in effect the memories or the
the personality traits of destiny and
then plants them into her mind then at
that point mystique again pretending to
be xavier's like well this is a very
very delicate process right so i'll hang
back here and get this sorted out you
guys go celebrate and do your thing
right which basically kind of shunts
them off and then following that it's
the recovery process now this if
anything was a testament to the
relationship between mystique and irene
adler right mystique and destiny that
given the history of these two right the
romantic relationship they've had the
fact that they've been together for so
long the death of destiny was this just
crushing moment for mystique right
because in that moment she had seemingly
lost everything that meant anything to
her in her life for destiny herself to
be returned to mystique and from
mystique to have her back creates a
sense of unity and wholeness that
neither one of them have had for quite
some time the kicker to this is that
because of the fact that destiny has
been gone for so long that all these
things that have happened in the past
and all these things are going to happen
in the future just come flooding back at
one time and that was kind of the nature
of destiny right because as she began to
use her powers and realized what she was
capable of that where they started off
as dreams then she started to realize
they were actually precognitive visions
she was able to ease into it and she was
able to kind of grasp everything that
was happening because she was able to
see them at a reasonable and slow pace
because they were coming at a reasonable
and slow pace right this is like you not
reading comics for like 15 years and
then i come along with every single
issue of comics that you missed and just
sitting them in front of you and say
here you go right it's it's overwhelming
it's immensely overwhelming and so for
her it just it almost kind of seems to
shut her down right it's just it's more
than she can handle and so what we get
is this kind of explanation that the
first week that destiny returned by the
seemingly endless atemporal waves of
future possibilities that were
completely and totally alien to her
right she was lost a seer out of time
but as hard as the first week was the
second week was most difficult why
because love brought destiny back that
and the underlying loyalty of a wife
desperate to be reunited with her wife
however while destiny was unchanged
frozen in time from the time they last
saw one another mystique had changed
it's not as though she died like a year
and a half ago right so it's like right
before the events of krakowa she's been
gone for a long long time and everything
that happened in between made mystique
harder and a lot of that was just
because of the fact that mystique really
experiencing the death of destiny losing
something that's significant to her made
her a hard person and the funny thing
about it is that this kind of hardness
that mystique had that was the shell
that was an exterior that mystique
didn't think she was still that
vulnerable anymore and talking to
destiny and seeing and actually
realizing right the reality of the
situation that destiny is truly back
it's not some kind of vision it's not
like she gets to have a moment with her
she is actually back forever more until
such a time as she dies in the future
just overwhelms mystique and she just
just totally falls apart it's not
something she thought she could
experience anymore but the important
thing is that with that the two of them
now being back together they have a they
have a heart where they have a greater
purpose so so week three was them just
kind of enjoying the company of one
another right week four was making plans
and so that goes into the the final
issue that we had which was destiny
being brought on to the quiet council
now here's the issue everyone here knows
who destiny is they know who she is they
know what she's capable of right they
know what she stands for and so xavier
is just kind of like okay so i have two
votes that i want to call right and then
destiny immediately calls him on the
first one and says do you really want to
vote to get mystique out of here because
i can tell you exactly how it's going to
happen right so then that leads into the
second vote right and the second vote is
basically to allow destiny on the quiet
council now seemingly destiny knows how
all this is going to play out but this
is a genius move by jonathan hickman he
doesn't tell us right destiny doesn't
even tell us she doesn't say like here's
how it's all actually going to happen
here's what's going to take place here
because in reality if she did it would
seemingly curtail the vote i would have
to imagine in this particular scenario
that it would be better it would be more
interesting for destiny and really more
enjoyable to watch xavier and to watch
uh magneto fail than it is to basically
tell them that they're going to fail
right to see the shock on their faces
not only that a lot of back alley deals
have been made here right that what you
of course have is is magneto and xavier
who were like no destiny cannot join the
quiet council right storm votes against
it as well but then nightcrawler votes
yes but he only votes yes because he
wants to appease his mom which actually
mystique was counting on from there it
goes to exodus now benedu paris has
always been just this really really
interesting character right he's
stupidly powerful right i mean his
telepathy is is astronomical and i mean
this guy is is i would say he's beyond
anybody here right beyond emma frost and
beyond xavier kind of depends on the
circumstance but he was created by
apocalypse right this guy's power is
virtually unrivaled by any of the
superheroes on earth you know minus the
reality warpers and you gotta throw
those in there but there was a deal that
was struck between destiny and exodus
right and then exodus basically said
like over the course of my life i've
been used for one cause or the other but
here on krakowa i'm my own man right no
one uses me here i have my own outlook
on this world i make my own decisions
and i decide what my fate will be so if
you are going to come to me and you are
going to ask me for your support and
bringing somebody on and you're not
telling me who they are or what they're
capable of or why you even want them in
the first place then i can't be bribed
here you're going to have to give me a
good reason now exodus is what you call
a believer this guy believes in krakowa
right because it's really the only place
that one he's felt safe and two he's
felt like he belonged and so that's what
mystique says the person that i'm
bringing on here can ensure the survival
of this place that she says like there
is a prophet to be resurrected right now
exodus very much believes in the idea of
prophets he believes in the idea of
those individuals out there that can
ensure their survival by seeing their
future and so because that's such an
intricate part of his character she says
like what if i told you that prophet had
a name and that name was the same as
what she offered a destiny what would
you say then and the response of exodus
is amen right like he he immediately is
in so he of course votes yes right at
that point it follows up to the point
when she went to go visit sinister again
all of this happening before the actual
vote for for destiny and of course she
says like i need your help with this and
he's like why would i do that like give
me a good give me a good argument right
give me a good point why should i side
with you here right i mean honestly i
have my own motivations but i also kind
of enjoy seeing you fail mystique so why
in the world would i agree to to support
you and your demands you know illuminate
good thespian spell it out for me and
she's like it's simple actually
everybody else is gonna demand that you
do it and sinister's like no one tells
sinister what to do i'm down
[Laughter]
so that's one of the funniest moments
for him so he's like i vote yes kitty
pride of course is like no not a chance
and then at that point they're tied four
to four so then it goes to uh to
sebastian shaw and sebastian shaw while
you would expect the fact that he has a
grudge against kitty pride and emma
frost and in turn would vote like in
support of it just despite kitty pride
it's actually a little bit deeper than
that it's actually exactly what you
would expect it would be like there's
actually there's a kind of fencing thing
right it's just them kind of doing their
thing right sebastian shaw loves fencing
and she's having a conversation with him
while all this is going on and he's like
so what do you intend to bribe me or
something she's like no i mean what
exists beyond the purse of the black
king right there's nothing out there in
the world that you can't buy she's like
so i'll give you a good reason right
i'll give you a better reason for why
you should vote in support of this and
when he asks what that reason is she's
like i know for a fact that emma frost
is going to vote against it and so
sebastian's like i'm in
[Laughter]
right that's one of the things like like
well you could look at this and you
could say oh my god look it's just
jonathan hickman doing stupid stuff no
the cool thing about this is it's petty
grudges that you look at the the quiet
council and what you expect is for
something grander here right you expect
these individuals who sit on this
governing body of the the mutant
population right the whole of the mutant
population lives and dies by the
decisions that the quiet council makes
and you expect them to rise above such
petty things but the message that
hickman is conveying here is no at the
end of the day they're every bit as
petty as you think they are they see
themselves as being something better
when in reality they're not and so what
you do is you switch over to really this
final vote right that you basically have
a five to four vote that you basically
have yet another tied vote and so you
end up switching to emma frost and at
that point what mystique has done here
was just bribe emma frost why she
presents her with something that emma's
been trying to get her hands on for
quite some time mystique was able to
secure it and then when she brings it to
emma the response is i will give it to
you but only if you will do something
for me right there's going to be a vote
at the next council meeting and the
white king and the white queen is going
to vote yes and so emma frost does that
and what it does is it solidifies the
role of destiny on the quiet council and
so at that point we switch over to orcas
now one of the cool things that
hickman's done here if you guys recall
with orcis they're more akin to
something like advanced idea mechanics
right or like the enclave or something
like that that while they are composed
of advanced idea mechanics and hydra and
all that kind of stuff all these
different uh scientific minds and even
in some cases straight up villainous
minds that they're largely operating
behind the scenes right they were
responsible for bringing nimrod online
and all that kind of stuff but they've
largely been working to try to find a
way to take out the entirety of the
mutant population seemingly by trying to
find a way to hijack their gates but the
important thing here is that while the
initial mission or this initial attempt
is yet another failure they've made a
little more progress than they did
before but you get a little bit of of
mystery going on here in the sense that
you have omega who again is formally in
omega sentinel those created by bastian
who was emerging of the original nimrod
and the sentinel creator master mold
into one mind that omega still kind of
exists out there but is basically
serving or operating seemingly against
the mutant population that has this
conversation with nimrod and one of the
things that we learn here is that
nimrod's been running simulations in
effect nimrod's been growing smarter
that nimrod's been running all these
different simulations trying to make
himself more powerful more capable what
if he faces off against this mutant or
that mutant different things like that
facing his own destruction and then
coming back again that sort of a thing
and the whole idea behind this is that
apparently that they are ready for some
kind of a conversation we don't really
know what it is we're not really given
any explanation here instead it's just
very very cloak and dagger but i cover
this because i feel like that's going to
become very important later on down the
line if i'm being honest with you i
think omega is a spy i think she's
working for the x-men population on
orcas and pretending to be a villain
because she was at one point kind of a
hero right so i think that's what's
really going on with it i don't know
[Laughter]
but i'd like to believe that that's
what's actually taking place but the
other part of this is that if you guys
recall the last video that destiny had
actually caught up to maura mctaggart
when she realized what maureen mctaggart
was doing dying coming back reliving
these lives different things like that
and the warning she gave her is that if
you continue this we will destroy you
right we'll officially kill you we'll go
back to when you were a little child
before your powers manifest and will
destroy you so that you are officially
dead forever more what more mctaggart is
doing here flies in the face of the
order she was given by mystique and
destiny more so than that the fact that
destiny's returned seems to really
indicate that like more mctaggart is
facing her own mortality she's afraid
she's gonna die and that's what she says
like destiny it'll take her no time at
all to figure out what's going on with
you guys right to figure out there's
something that you guys are doing you're
working with some third party and then
from that point it's only a matter of
time before she realizes it's me and
when that happens sure her a mystique
they'll burn all this down they'll
destroy all of this they'll kill you
then they'll kill me right they will
come after us and so at that point it's
kind of like okay they kind of get into
this discussion about like we have to
kill destiny now this is a side of more
mctaggart at least as is hint to that
this is the side of maura mctaggart that
xavier and magneto haven't seen before
and that's the important thing to
understand that from more of metagrass
perspective this kind of greater goal of
ensuring the mutant population survival
or at least that seems to be the case
that's the most important thing and
everybody here including xavier and
magneto themselves they're expendable
and so seeing that from morgan
mctaggart's perspective while it doesn't
leave them to abandon maura mctaggart it
does change the way they see her right
it's just kind of like like she's having
this discussion about like the pragmatic
action of just killing destiny and when
the question's asked like can you guys
do it magneto says i mean she wears a
hell a metal helmet on her head right
like i could just crush the helmet and
kill her but i'm not going to do that
and when the question asks why he says
like it or not she sits on the council
i'm not a child i can tolerate a certain
level of pragmatism when it comes to how
things are run here in paradise but i
have waited my whole life for this place
i will not defile it just because you
find it expedient right it's it's kind
of an amazing stance from magneto that
from his perspective this mutant nation
of krakowa a land where the mutant
population can live absent the fear of
death at the hands of the human
population is what he's always wanted
the way he's gone about it has been
questionable over the years but at the
end of the day he does say however there
is still a seat that needs filling maybe
we make our own offer that cannot be
refused now when he's talking about this
he's not talking about the idea of the
quiet council he's talking about this
inner council right that they bring
somebody in they bring someone in and
give them the truth of what's happening
here that maury mctaggart and charles
xavier and and magneto are working
together that there's actually a grander
plan at play here and seemingly no one
else out there in the quiet council or
the entire mutant population know about
it and so what you end up doing is
switching over to what is basically this
kind of this this scenario at the louvre
when this telepathic instruction is
given to all the tourists there and when
they're all gone they end up bringing in
emma frost that emma frost from their
perception is the one person they can
trust now there's good reason for this
right there's good reason for this emma
frost yes she did historically start out
as a villain when she was introduced in
the old x-men stories by chris claremont
right she was a member of the hellfire
club but the death of the hellions
changed emma frost right the hellions
were like her own version of the new
mutants right her own kind of teenage
villainous team and they would
constantly fight against the new mutants
but the actions of emma frost that
graveyage conflict the death of the
hellions themselves changed her
irrevocably and so that's why she
actually joined the x-men and then
became the leader of generation x and
has essentially been a hero ever since
it changed the way in which she saw the
world her loyalties to kokoa to xavier
to magneto to the cause they are beyond
contestation here no one could ever
question that that she's done a couple
of unsavory things but at the end of the
day it was all for furthering the
mission of xavier and magneto so when
they come to her and they say we want
you to be a part of this that when she
initially sees morgan mctaggart she's
like okay that's kind of cool i thought
you were dead but if she is really the
center of all of this then why she's a
human right why would a human be at the
center of the formation of kokoa and the
motivation and reasoning for why it was
done and the response of xavier is she's
not a human she's a mutant and if you
don't believe me read her mind right
it'd be a much easier thing for emma
frost to read the mind of maura
mctaggart than for them to like sit down
and explain everything right so she
literally does that reads the mind of
maura mctaggart and then is just kind of
overwhelmed by what she sees this grand
motivation and all this stuff but then
at that point she's like don't touch me
i don't want to have anything to do with
any of you and of course the response to
magneto is i understand how you feel it
was difficult when i first learned of
all of this and then the question is
asked how long ago was that how long ago
was it that you learned about this that
you learned about all these futures
where the entire mutant population is
totally obliterated completely and
totally wiped out that more mctagger
came to you with all this stuff and said
we're gonna form cocoa we're gonna do
all this stuff for the grander good how
long was it that you knew about that and
the question is dodged right the
question is dodged quite a bit right
like they never really give her a
definitive answer and so maureen
mctaggart steps up and says okay fine
you feel left out that's understandable
but notice she says here but that's
looking at all of this the wrong way
outside of us you're the first one that
we let in and the response of xavier is
because we trust you and the response of
magneto is it's more than that we need
you emma your nation needs you they try
to appeal to her i guess patriotism if
you want to call it that and she ponders
for a second of course notice she turns
into her diamond form which you can't
read her mind in her diamond form and
she says of course for the children but
because of the fact of everything that's
happened because she was essentially
sold a lie by xavier magneto she was
never told the truth about what all's
happening here despite the fact that she
has displayed over and over and over
again that her loyalties are to never be
questioned she says you've manipulated
me for years and now i can see what kind
of threat a pre-cod represents well i am
a true mutant i sit on the council so
i'll give the matter the proper
consideration but my loyalty you
arrogant fools have lost that forever
now this is huge because the question
they're left asking here is did we just
make an enemy out of emma frost and if
they did she's the last person you want
to make an enemy out of because while
xavier and magneto are the ones that
kind of run this whole show the reality
is all these different members of the
quiet council storm and nightcrawler
mystique destiny now emma frost exodus
sebastian shaw they've all got their own
contacts they've all got their own
networks private networks public
networks underground networks black
markets different things like that the
last thing you want is someone like emma
frost that has
wildly high levels of telepathy that has
the loyalty of a lot of mutants at her
disposal and has her own network to be
your enemy because emma frost could be a
one-man army not only that she's
intricate to cocoa so all she has to do
is just cut off the entirety of krakow's
ability to send its medicines out into
the world or to seed some kind of
disdain against the mutant population by
sowing lies in the minds of people using
her telepathy and suddenly they have
this just massive calamity they have to
contend with there's a thousand ways she
could screw over xavier and magneto it's
the last person you want to have against
you and so following that a final vote
is issued for a missing seat right for
the final seat of the of the the quiet
council right this final vote issue
xavier says we've put the name forth
that name has rung out right so you guys
are about to vote on this person a
mutant to join our number and fill the
final seat of the quiet council so now
we vote and so at that point sinister's
like you know what i don't like the way
this one looks so no exodus votes yes
mystique votes no right kitty pride
votes yes emma frost votes yes sebastian
shaw of course votes no because he's a
dick nightcrawler is like i am overjoyed
to vote yes right i've known this person
for a very long time storm says yes
right xavier yes magneto yes destiny no
and so it's 7 4 4 against and he says we
have once again added to our number now
we are whole welcome brother we are
honored to have colossus join the quiet
council with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching
god i love colossus and i will catch you
all later
peace